welcome back to Piers Morgan on sensor
it's a social media Trend so bizarre I'm
not even going to pretend that I
understand it but just take a look
it's my birthday
[Music]
hey hi yes the guy feel like a cowgirl
and you're ready
[Music]
do New York Times and other media these
are grown adults performing as
non-playable characters they can make
thousands of dollars from fans who pay
to feed them digital treats or Pat them
on the head now Tick Tock is fun I like
teacher a massive on Twitter but is it
rotting our brains with this crap I'm
joined by Tick Tock star J Monique the
host of Babylon B Ashley Claire well
welcome to both of you and talk TV
presenter Rosanna Lockwood lurking to
fill in my seat after I go
um all right let's talk about this first
J Money sell this to me it looks
completely predators to me why is this
good and why is it so successful
because
it's the way to make money just quickly
just easily for people but it's also fun
it was like fun train no I get it but I
mean people telling you to do stupid
things and then you do them for money I
mean it is a bit like low rent low level
stuff I mean you're licking your tongue
you're licking the screen it's like it's
just weird isn't it
oh
I am a cosplayer so I cosplayed on my
tick tocks
um when I first started so it's not as
weird to me okay so it was definitely
something fun and something good for my
like my personality okay uh ashes and
glare look it's a bit of harmless fun
it's the kind of tick tock generation
love it why are we being such terrible
killjoys
I don't know that it's really harmless
fun I think in a
go ahead I think in a way and you I
unders I understand that some people you
know they're making good money and
that's appealing but in a way you're
selling your soul to this quasi-soft
core sex app in a way it's being
fetishized you're telling young girls
that have aspirations to be engineers
and other aspirations that they could
make quick money on Tick Tock which is
owned by bite dance and by proxy the CCP
that this is the way to make money this
is what you should do
I mean look there is a point there Jay
isn't it I mean I hear that argument but
then I guess my you know young people
will be watching this game listen you
old fuddy duddy you just don't get it
um definitely but um most kids do not
know or people do not know that it's
even a fetish so when we hopped on this
train it was just something fun it's
just something to do like every other
dance that is done on Tick Tock it was a
trend it was nice it was cool it was fun
people made it
something too serious everybody wants to
put their opinion in their own mindset
on things and kind of deliver a
different message than what people are
really intending it to be which is just
fun and something to make a little extra
money actually you had a little go at
this we've got a clip of you in action I
think
mmm ice cream's so good yummy hot dog gg
gg thank you for the likes
ice cream's so good
I'm watching that thank you maybe I'm in
the wrong wrong game I should be doing
stuff like this for money
no it's to be clear obviously that was
cropped and the rest the the rest of the
video I was talking about BlackRock and
you know engaging in some of the infosex
war but I think Jay especially you you
have a lot of followers I think there's
some responsibility to be a role model
especially to these young girls here and
I understand that it's easy money but at
the end of the day your money is
dependent on an algorithm that is run
and created by people who are
ontologically evil the CCP and bite
dance and your views and your money is
now dependent on performing for that
algorithm on creating content for that
algorithm okay listen I've got to leave
it with you two uh We've run out of time
thank you both very much indeed
interesting debate about something I
knew nothing about let's bring in
Rosanna you've got the thankless task of
trying to replace me for the next few
weeks while I go and land or a palm tree
um honor to be your last hurray this
kind of thing I mean am I just too old
it's you're asking the right questions I
think what does this lead Society to but
it is fun come on ice cream's so good
ice cream's so good it is very addictive
viewing and it's an honest way to make
some cash it's not only fat and it's not
like what I think against that either
but it's it's it's it's pretty harmless
well talking of harmless fun let's bring
in the graphic I think we've got we've
got behind me a little bit of palm trees
there we go there we go I don't like it
you've been basically ramming down your
Instagram pictures of yourself on
various beaches around the world in the
last couple of weeks and I now intend to
go off and do exactly the same to you so
you can be looking forward to pictures
of me lying on hammocks under palm trees
while you slave away at the Piers Morgan
uncensored toll face good luck to you
Rosanna thank you peers honor to the
collaborating you again enjoy your
holiday take care